What, what do you think? Uh,
the biggest since we're covering every single possible topic for me ask the
biggest one, the unanswerable one,
from the perspective of alien intelligence or from the perspective of religious
studies or from the perspective of just Diana,
what do you think is the meaning of this existence of, uh,
this life of ours?
Yes. Okay. So, all right. So.
Well of.
Course I have to,
my philosophical training as a undergrad always makes me
think about, like, what's the assumption in your question.
There's an assumption there it's like, there is a meaning. Okay.
That's the assumption.
What do you mean by life? You define the terms.
No, no, but listen. Okay. I'll answer your question.
I'm just going to say that there's this assumption that we should have meaning
to life. Okay. Well maybe we should. We shouldn't, maybe it was just all random.
Okay. However, I believe that it's not, and in my opinion,
on the meaning of life, in my opinion is an intrinsic. I enjoy living.
I want to live sometimes I don't enjoy living. And when I don't enjoy living,
I change my circumstances. So it's intrinsic.
And I think that certain things are intrinsic and like, love,
love of your children is kind of, um, well, it's actually a physiological,
but it's also intrinsic. It's beautiful. You know,
there's something about it that that is intrinsically,
um, desirable. So the,
I think the meaning of life is like that intrinsically designed.
So it's something that just was born inside you
based on, um, what makes you feel good?
No, that's hedonism. That's.
It's about what, uh, where do you place love, love, love of your children.
Yeah. So basically, um,
loving your children by the way is not always easy because they do things that
they shouldn't do. You have to discipline them.
That's one of the worst things about Parenthood to me is disciplining my
children. I don't like to do that. I love them. Um,
so a lot of things that I do that I feel are
good are not easy. So there's an intrinsic sense that like,
okay, let's take, um, animals. Okay. So we have dogs and cats. Okay.
So you might not, but I do, I've, you know, I told you about them.
Can you, can you, can you, uh, share their names?
If I share their names, I will share their names. Okay.
So we have a cat and it has red, fluffy hair. And so we called it Trump.
Well, when we got our dog, we figured that it needed a companion.
So we called it Putin. So we have Trump and Putin.
Greatest pet names of all time. I'm sorry.
And, uh, or maybe we'll be able to share a picture of your cat,
cause this is awesome. Very photogenic.
Uh, I mean this something that's, uh, whether LA, uh, what,
whether we're talking about love or the intrinsic meaning,
do you think that's something that's really special to humans
or if there is intelligent alien civilizations out there,
do you think that's something that they possess as well? Um,
maybe in different forms, like whatever,
this thing that meaning is this inter
instrinsic drive that we have, do you think that's just a property of life,
of some level of complexity that we will see that everywhere in this
universe.
In my opinion, and this is just my opinion. Um, I, I do think that it is,
but I also think that it could take different forms. So if there is like, uh,
think of gravity, right? Gravity kind of like make stuff, stick to it, right.
It could track stuff. Well, what is love do you that does that too. Right?
So people who are CR we call them cruise Matic, charism.
It means love charism means light and love.
So a charismatic person is a person who attracts people to them,
like the sun does. Right. Like, you know, so, um,
so I think that whatever this property is,
that's intrinsic is like gravity.
And most likely it takes different forms in different types of life forms.
Yeah. I can't wait until like, uh,
Albert Einstein type of figure in the future will discover that love is in fact,
one of the fundamental forces of physics. That would be cool,
Anna. And this is one of the favorite conversations I've ever had.
It's truly an honor to talk to you and thank you so much for spending all this
time.